and the Oscar goes to Brad Pitt thank
you incredible really incredible Brad
Pitt took home its first acting Oscar on
Sunday night for his role in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood and he gave a rare
shout-out to his six children during his
acceptance speech this is for my kids
everything I do
I adore you Brad also had a message for
his director Quentin Tarantino I loved
ethos she gave cliff Boothe look for the
best in people expect the worst but look
for the best and said this to his
co-star Leonardo DiCaprio Leo I'll write
on your coattails any day man
the views fantastic Brad got a little
nostalgic on stage I'm not one to look
back but this is made me do so and I
think of my folks taking me to the
drive-in to see Butch and Sundance and
loading up my car and moving out here
and Gina and Ridley give me my first
shot to all the wonderful people I've
met along the way and also got a little
political they told me I only have 45
seconds up here which is 45 seconds more
than the Senate gave John Bolton this
week
I'm thinking maybe Quentin doesn't move
you about it in the end the adults do
the right thing and he perfectly wraps
things up with a nod to his movie once
upon a time in Hollywood he bets truth
ET folk with brad ahead of the show
where he wasn't so sure he would take
home the oscar what does this night mean
and what it could be and the excitement
of tonight so it's exciting to get to
the end it's exciting too for it to be
the biggest of the biggest and it'll be
exciting to you know get back to work
know what it's like everybody everybody
is like yeah everybody do you have more
jokes written for tonight you're BAFTA
speech was off the chain and I think you
know you got a few folks know I'm going
all I'm going all like downer tonight
it's my plan I know you and what will
this mean do you go home and you hold
the Oscar with the kids you run around
and you all get a touch of it I don't
think it's gonna go that way but I don't
know who knows who knows come on I told
you what the clothes I know
who knows what's gonna happen
[Music]